the two nordic countries of sweden and
finland are pushing forward on their
landmark bids to join the nato military
alliance for sweden joining nato would
mean giving up more than two centuries
of neutrality public opinion in favor of
joining nato grew to around 50 percent
after russia's invasion of ukraine
but nato expansion is being opposed by
member country turkey president recep
tayyip erdogan has accused sweden of
supporting opposition groups it labels
terrorists and is angered over sweden's
embargo on arms sales to turkey all 30
nato members must approve expansion bids
the issue is expected to dominate
discussions at a nato summit at the end
of june
i'm not joined by sweden's defense
minister peter holdquist
from stockholm welcome to dw
uh you said publicly last year that you
would quote never allow sweden to join
nato as long as you were defense
minister why do you turn now
the situation
before 24th of february was one
situation and a situation after the
russian attack against ukraine was an is
another
um
we have a situation when we have a
real war in our neighborhood and that
has changed the situation fundamentally
and
we have also decided after security
analysis to go to nato membership
together with finland so it was one
situation before and it's one situation
often
now turkey is
threatening to block your accession do
you think you'll be able to persuade
president edward to lift his veto
we have a dialogue with turkey and also
with
different countries inside nato and also
with the general secretary
and our ambition is to solve this
problem
now ankara says both sweden and finland
have a kurdish activists and people
linked to the gulen movement who whom it
considers terrorists uh is that true
uh we have cured this uh
we have people with curious spectrum
that are swedish citizens and
they hate from that point of view that
they are equal as other citizens in the
swedish society
the problem we now have with turkey we
will try to solve and we have a
diplomatic dialogue about that
so are you prepared to make concessions
to turkey by extraditing or expelling
activists
we are
we we have this dialogue and we will
comment that when the
so-called problem is solved
are you confident that you will be able
to convince erdogan
as i said we have a diplomatic dialogue
and i have to refer to that and
you are you must also have respect for
that sweden tried to solve this question
together with the other friends inside
nato
now sweden has over many years like many
other countries cut its defense budget
until recently now it's hard to spend
big on re-armament how prepared is
sweden actually for a worst-case
scenario
your description is wrong because we
started with a defense decision
2015 and between 2014 and 2025
we increased the budget with 80 percent
eight zero percent
and uh
added to this we have this year decided
to put two more
two more swedish billion crowns into the
defense budget and we also decided to go
up to two percent of gdp and
connected to the what the armed forces
says we can do that 2020
now what changes are we likely to see on
the ground if sweden joins the alliance
would you for example allow nato troops
or even nuclear weapons onto your
territory
i don't think that it's uh an uh
question that
are on the agenda that we should have
nuclear weapons i think we have the same
position as norway
the whole idea to be a member of nato is
also that we will have nato
representations in different sort of
exercises and activities on swedish soil
and i think that what we can do together
is that in from a nordic perspective
make a deep strategical deep on the
military operation arena so i think we
can build a higher level and higher
threshold towards russia with nato
membership
now this is a historic shift for sweden
uh is your identity as a neutral
peaceful non-aligned nation now
completely lost
i think this is a wrong description
because
our values is the same values at other
countries in europe for example germany
and
and others that we we try to create
peace and we try to create peaceful
solutions but we are not naive we see
the development around us and
we must also make conclusions from from
that situation now we have the
first big war in our neighborhood since
the second world war so there is a
fundamental change and and it's 100
percent russia's responsibility
the swedish defense minister peter
holdquist there thank you very much
thank you
now voters in denmark are going to the
polls today in a referendum on whether
their country should join the european
union's common defense policy denmark is
an eu member but after a 1992 vote it
negotiated exemptions on various
policies including defense but now
against the backdrop of russian
aggression danes are being asked whether
they still want to opt out of eu defence
planning
denmark has a history of saying no to
europe in referendums it has long been
concerned about a closer union and being
swallowed up by bigger neighbors
only 30 years ago they decided to opt
out of a common european defense policy
danes wanted nothing to do with it and
the eu went ahead without them the
strategic situation the jail strategy
changes
show
that now we need a stronger europe
while european countries were looking
for more military cooperation
denmark rather focused on its membership
in nato just recently they increased
their presence in estonia to help
protect the baltics against russian
aggression
but it was russia's invasion of ukraine
that finally changed the political mood
and copenhagen
in spite of traditional euroscepticism
there is also a a realization
amongst the public that that we are in a
crisis situation so maybe it's not that
bad an idea to reconsider
how denmark is participating in eu in
security defense
prime minister mata frederickson called
a referendum on whether to reverse
course and opt in to the eu's joint
defence policies
us who are gathered here tonight have
agreed that a referendum will be held on
the 1st of june this year
we very strongly urge the danes to
abolish the defense reservation at
austrav forces
opinion ports foresee a majority for yes
but parties on the extreme left and
right are campaigning against giving up
the opt out option and danes have been
known to change their minds before